[Applause]
people power will win these protesters
are chanting they celebrated a small
moment of victory when they heard
president gotabaya rajapaksa had fled
but soon after his early morning escape
the mood turned to anger
thousands of people marched to the
office of the man they fear could be
rajapaksa's successor ranil become a
singer he can gain the power he can
mobilize the military and he can crash
out the whole protesters and he can so
gain the power and no offence will come
to you that's the plan he's a mastermind
and please i am asking international
community don't trust vikramazinga he is
the biggest villain in sri lanka in
response the prime minister declared a
state of emergency saying he was now the
acting president security forces in
front of his office fired tear gas at
protesters dozens were injured
this teacher needed treatment after
being hit on the head he traveled 150
kilometers to join the demonstrations
saying the government has ruined the
education system the prime minister is
very cunning fox he's
ruined my country we won't win our
revolution
outnumbered security forces failed to
disperse the crowds a couple of members
of the security forces what looks like
the riot police are now being chased
away from the prime minister's office
after several attacks by tear gas
they're now
chased away by the crowds
they're leaving
[Applause]
[Music]
protesters managed to break through the
gates of the prime minister's office and
took over the building their celebration
did not last long they went to the
residence of the parliamentary speaker
to make sure the prime minister would
step down and were greeted by more tear
gas
potassiums blame both rajapaksa and
vikramasingha for the dire state sri
lanka is in bankrupt hardly any fuel and
food shortages sri lanka as a country so
it's it's run by a few families for
seven decades who robbed our country so
this should be changed so at least uh
this this major shift these people's
revolution should ensure that a new
political social
age
begins in sri lanka
until then they have vowed to remain on
the streets and keep a close eye on what
parliament which has the power to elect
the new president will decide in coming
days step fast in al jazeera colombo